angry Democrats slinging mud during a
heated Russia hoax hearing on Capitol
Hill special counsel John Durham
testifying and trying to tell America
that the FBI put their thumb on the
scale and had no business investigating
the Trump campaign Durham calling for
accountability
as we said in the report they cannot be
addressed solely by enhancing training
or additional policy requirements rather
what is required is accountability
both in terms of the standards to which
our law enforcement Personnel hold
themselves and in the consequences they
face for violation of laws and policies
of relevance the Democrats didn't care
about the facts and overwhelming
evidence of bias at the FBI instead it
was attack attack
Mr Durham your report reads like a
defense of the Trump campaign in an
attack on Hillary Clinton because that's
exactly what it is Donald Trump wanted
you to investigate the investigators to
show the Deep state conspiracy but you
never found one you had a good
reputation that's why the two Democrats
supported you but the longer you hold on
to Mr Barr in this report that Mr Barr
gave you a special counsel
your reputation will be damaged my
concern about my reputation is with the
people who I respect and my family and
my Lord
and I'm perfectly comfortable with my
reputation with them sir and when you
say you're not aware of evidence of
collusion the mother report it's because
apparently I haven't read the mail
report very well
um I don't want to adjust your
television you just saw the king of the
Russia hoax himself Adam Schiff grilling
Durham speaking of which the
householding a vote to censure the
disgraced Congressman for pushing
debunked claims of collusion but he
doesn't seem phased this is a badge of
honor driven by
extreme Maga members of the house and
Donald Trump threatening Republicans
with retaliation if they don't vote on
this bogus resolution this says that I'm
effective they go after people they
think are effective Judge Jeanine Pirro
did you learn anything new from the
Durham hearing today
well I didn't learn anything new from
the Durham hearing other than the
Democrats continue to be delusional in
their determination to make it look as
though there is still a trump Russia
connection and Durham couldn't have been
more clear with evidence we already know
to be the case that there was no Trump
Russia collusion and the amazing part of
it is he said there was no basis in fact
to even begin the investigation I don't
know if you remember but way back in the
beginning they kept saying what was the
basis for the investigation what date
did you start this investigation on and
the Dems were very Coy they would never
come up with it because they had no
facts no basis no complaint now I think
that I think that Durham is absolutely
correct when he says
um that that this is it's not about
enhancing it's not about changing the
rules it's not about training it's about
truth and honesty you don't need to
change the rules you just can't lie you
can't be a McCabe or a stroke and lie
you can't have confirmation bias where
you believe something to be true and
that's really giving them a pass they
created it they knew they created all of
them were in on it and Brennan I know in
one of my books I talked about him as
the chief scum uh in the in the Deep
State Brandon is the one who knew and
spread it around to everyone else and
who was that everyone else they're still
on television you've got Brennan Clapper
uh you've got strzok and McCabe they're
on television and they're saying you
know what this is all about protecting
Trump this is nothing to do with Trump
other than exonerating him and it's got
nothing to do with indicting Hillary
Clinton because nobody's going to indict
him but the truth is the people who made
it up the people who told Biden and
Obama that they were making it up that
they were going to destroy this country
and have everyone at each other's necks
got away with it and we suffered from
all of the backlash and when Brennan
found out it was a a Clinton conspiracy
he tells Comey and then Comey keeps that
information from Crossfire investigators
yeah and one of the things that Durham
reported and this is under question I
Believe by Jim Jordan was that the rep
that the lawyer when they're
interviewing him when he finds out about
this he's so upset that he had to leave
the room he went out and he said he was
almost near tears in terms of
frustration embarrassment anger and
they're like oh sorry I'm like no
actually this really matters the a word
that Durham used repeatedly was that the
findings that he had were sobering and
then he used a word that's what's needed
is accountability
and I think it's the accountability part
that's like not happening I don't see it
happening and I don't know if even
anybody on either side would be
satisfied with accountability the left
has decided that they think that doj and
FBI are biased against them the right
things that the FBI and the doj are
biased against the right so I I don't
know actually really don't know how you
deal with that Durham to me was a very
credible public servant he had to sit
there and take it from somebody like
Adam Schiff who that very day his being
censured by the house for perpetrating
the whole thing he talked about how he
spent four years away from his family
dealing with this thing and he has to
imagine because of you you and now
you're you are in a position of power
and this and the house in order to
question me Adam Schiff loved this today
and the house members were helping him
to basically raise a lot of small dollar
money he's in a primary in a fight in
California he wants to get that senate
seat that Dianne Feinstein is likely
going to vacate or the one that um that
they hoped to be able to win all of all
of those guys have to be looking at this
going wow Adam Schiff is the one who's
going to come out on top of this thing
on the Democratic side I mean that is
that is just Washington DC for you Tulsi
before these hearings how does this work
did the staff get together they come up
with these talking points so the members
get together and stay on message is
there a strategy here that's what
happens every time and that's why you
see the lines of attack they actually do
go through that preparation and they
figure out okay who's going to take this
line of attack who's going to take this
other line of attack so that they're not
all saying the exact same thing but
they're all they're all going back to
the same major point which is a reminder
to all of us of the power of the Hillary
Clinton machine that extends across the
National Security State uh you know the
propaganda media big Tech it's a
reminder of the Democrats Playbook I've
had some experience with of refusing to
address substance and evidence and
instead immediately going towards smear
and destruction and and outright saying
you know we will destroy your reputation
they're not making any uh there's no
qualms about exactly what their
objective is and I agree with him yes
accountability is what's necessary here
I have no faith that will it will occur
for the reasons that Dana talked about
and and especially under the Biden
Administration I think what really needs
to happen again I agree with Durham you
can't just nibble around the edges with
the FBI they're so endemically corrupt
and politicized at this point there
needs to be a top to bottom overhaul or
just disband the FBI and come up with a
new agency and start fresh and charge
people with the actual responsibility
FBI should be fulfilling it's hard to
get accountability because Durham never
even interviewed Comey never subpoenaed
McCabe never subpoenaed Glenn Simpson I
wonder why I don't know this is the
problem will historians actually write
this fairly because this is somebody
they truly despised right today's
historians despise Trump they're just
going to get older and write more books
so no matter what happens here the truth
is never going to get out and I think
that's I mean we're kind of it's kind of
a depressing story and the way that you
know Republicans really aren't good at
this because politics isn't personal for
them so they can't do the theater the
way the Democrats do and so what you
watched today was kind of an Oham it
wasn't that exciting uh when you aren't
a liberal scandals
you know they just don't work for you
you know what I mean the Press controls
the outcome uh the Dems do political
theater better than anybody else and you
even have Adam Schiff gets to grill the
actual investigator how is that possible
that is it's an amazing thing I'm jaded
I guess I'm jaded how do you have
accountability when so many people are
in on it that's the problem and I do
think it would be great to see the FBI
disbanded but I can't believe I would
say that yeah because I used to I used
to watch FBI from Zimbalist Jr remember
that's how I learned Roman letters
was it Roman letters remember each part
segment would go part one all right
thanks you guys thank you thank you no
but I love that show and now we're like
everything that the Democrats touch
undermines it but one was television and
now you know the facts yeah
unfortunately I prefer TV me too but the
FBI the left used to want to disband the
FBI yeah the right does and then maybe
maybe they can agree on that I don't
know I don't want I don't know what to
do yeah I don't know no one on cable
news ever says that you're brave I don't
know hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else